bei mir im studio ist noch immer bild
vize franz immer voll sagt uns doch
einmal was jetzt sozusagen die
wichtigsten sachen waren die märkte
gerade gesagt hat ich glaube der
entscheidende satz den wir so von der
kanzler noch nicht gehört haben aus
dieser pressekonferenz ist dass sie
gesagt habe das ist eine
naturkatastrophe mit der wir umgehen
müssen also sie bezeichnet corona als
naturkatastrophe
sie verteidigt die harten maßnahmen sie
hat darauf hingewiesen dass sie und alle
also die politiker ein eid geleistet
haben
und sie verweist darauf dass deutschland
eine ältere gesellschaft ist dass es
viele ältere menschen gibt dass sie
diese älteren menschen schützen möchte
und sie sagt aber gleichzeitig dass es
kein weihnachten in einsamkeit sein soll
also sie hat durchaus hoffnung dass
durch den lockdown jetzt die zahlen
runter gehen dass man im dezember
vielleicht wieder teilweise dann öffnen
kann allerdings sagt sie sie möchte auch
darüber nicht spekulieren was dann
tatsächlich ende november ist ja wir
wollen jetzt über diese pressekonferenz
auch sprechen mit dem fdp-vize uns jetzt
zugeschaltet wolfgang kubicki
guten tag herr kubicki sie haben das
natürlich auch gerade alles mitverfolgt
unter anderem hat angela merkel auch
gesagt dass niemand jetzt alleine
gelassen wird der diesen monat schließen
muss in der gastro oder fitnesscenter
als beispiele wie beruhigend ist dass
für die vielen menschen in deutschland
in ihren augen
jetzt nächste die worte sind beruhigend
was am ende dabei herauskommen wird
werden wir sehen allein ständig als
technische abwicklung einer solchen
maßnahme die zehn milliarden euro
verteilen will wird eine tägliche
herausforderung seien viele kräfte
binden und auch wieder viele verletzte
auf dem feld zurück lassen
das ist momentan nicht mal ein punkt
mein punkt ist dass die bundeskanzlerin
über das hinaus was sie beweismittel
erklärt hat wenig gesagt außer wir
werden alle herren die mobilität
erreichen müssen außer gebrauchen an der
inzidenz zahl von weniger als 50 wobei
offen geblieben ist auch dass die jetzt
bundesweit gilt oder den einzel
landkreis das muss man nicht schon
wieder warten bis der letzte landkreis
in bayern unter 40.000 einwohner
gekommen ist und sie habe glaube ich
einen fehler begangen der daher besteht
dass sie gesagt wir müssen die kontakte
beschränken das ist nur teilweise
richtig wir müssen die kontakte
beschränken die ungeschützt geschehen
wenn die menschen der vfb zwei masken
tragen beispielsweise dann haben sie
kein infektionsrisiko oder können die
kontakte auch bestehen bleiben ich hätte
mir gewünscht hätte heute aufgefordert
als möglichst wie menschen nicht mehr
fdp zwei masten versorgen und damit
einen großen eigenschutz betreuen
herr kubicki die kanzlerin hat auch
gesagt dass das virus halbherzigkeit
bestrafen würde und hat diese maßnahmen
verteidigt indirekt auch gegen die
kritik aus ihrer partei ist das was sie
fordern halbherzig zunächst einmal sind
die einzige das fordern sondern es gibt
eine reihe von biologen gestern abend
noch mal professor will ich der
psychologe der charité in berlin
herrscht reger schmidt chanasit
der kollege palmer als oberbürgermeister
von tübingen macht das gerade das ffg
zwei masken an die alten und pflegeheime
verteilt und dort niemand mehr rein oder
raus kann der nie vorher getestet worden
ist etwas was ich beispielsweise eben
meist schon gefordert habe und die uns
fragen wir sind warum das so lange
gedauert hat ist es geschehen ist aber
wenn sie dann kontakt beschränkungen
machen wollen da dürfen sie jetzt keine
u-bahn s-bahn und erfahren lassen heute
morgen war es in berlin haben die u-bahn
wieder so eng an eng an eng mit einer
bestückt und menschen über 20 30 minuten
zusammengepfercht waren
und zwar nicht mit masken die den
eigenschutz beinhalten also insofern
wäre die kontakt beschränkung in der u
bahn
beim wesentlich sinnvoller als und
gastronomischen betrieben die mittel
jene patienten habe die kanzlerin sagt
auch über corona das ist eine
naturkatastrophe mit der wir umgehen
müssen teilen sie die analyse ist krone
eine naturkatastrophe
wenn jeden fall ist es an erhebliche
herausforderung für die medizin für die
wissenschaft wurde für die gesellschaft
insgesamt ich teile das das ist eine
wirklich große herausforderung ist aber
wir wollen nicht zurück schauen
gleichwohl gibt es eine reihe von fragen
bis heute nach acht monaten bin ich alle
gesundheitsämter an das elektronische
system dem ist angeschlossen also das
deutsche elektronische meldesystem
infektionen
dann hätte man ein lagebild was
ausreichend wäre wir haben immer noch
probleme mit der krone at man muss sich
wirklich fragen warum wir so viel geld
ausgegeben haben wenn die
funktionsfähigkeit eingeschränkt ist wir
sind doch ein land was technisch
versiert ist wir können doch genauso wie
taiwan oder südkorea mit elektronischen
möglichkeiten umgehen da ist
mittlerweile mehr nach zu arbeiten als
das den beteiligten lieb ist kubicki
viele menschen fragen sich natürlich
auch was passiert dann nach dem november
die kanzlerin wollte da jetzt nicht
spekulieren was ist ihr gefühl was haben
sie da mitgenommen aus der
pressekonferenz
glauben sie dass dann wieder geöffnet
wird oder haben sie das gefühl wenn sie
der kanzlerin zu hören dass dieser
lockdown viel länger dauern könnte also
von gefühlen wollen wir jetzt nicht
reden weil ich bin hin und hergerissen
zwischen optimismus dass wir es gewinnen
könnt auch mit der technik technische
innovation die wir haben wir die
medizinischen fortschritten und der
sorge dass man selbst gefangen ist in
der argumentation die man aufbaut was
passiert wenn wir ende november bei 52
inzidenz in deutschland weit über
hunderttausend sind wird er noch das
wort gesetzt und lange soll das
umgesetzt werden wie lange kann sich
dieses land leisten zehn milliarden euro
pro monat auszugeben dafür das
gastronomische betriebe waren das die
kunst nicht mehr stattfinden kann etwas
was ja auch zur gesundheit wir mussten
es immer wieder überlegen wir haben bei
allen maßnahmen die wir machen auch
kollateralschäden menschen vereinsamen
menschen werden depressiv menschen dem
er zum arzt menschen haben keine
lebensperspektive hat das ist auch ein
problem
wir brauchen auch planbarkeit wieder für
unsere wirtschaft all das wie gesagt ist
bisher nicht gegeben wenn wir nicht zur
planbarkeit des lebens zurückkommen
da wird die unsicherheit zu einem
wesentlichen faktor der
gesellschaftlichen spaltung werden und
vor allen dingen auch
wirtschaft wieder wächst jetzt ist
dieser locker und die entscheidung dazu
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gefallen es gibt schon seit längerem
viel kritik daran dass das ganze immer
vorbei am parlament vorbei an der
opposition entschieden wird was ist
jetzt ihr plant für die kommenden wochen
und monate wenn es im dezember
tatsächlich weitere lockt maßnahmen gibt
um als opposition dann dort auch ein
mitspracherecht zu haben
also zunächst wenig da kannst du kein
dankbar dass ich jetzt parlamenten
dieses beteiligen wie sie gesagt sie ist
gerade bereich zu berichten über
maßnahmen die mpk beschlossen dass wir
gemeinsam ist wichtiger dass wir vorher
diskutieren bevor maßnahmen ins werk
gesetzt werden immer nur noch berichten
entgegen leben darf dennoch einmal
stimmt der bundestag hat das
infektionsschutzgesetz novelliert im
märz wir haben verordnungsermächtigungen
geschaffen das sich für den bund für die
länder aber wir haben keine ermächtigung
geschaffen von der verordnung so
gebraucht so nah an das grundrechte
praktisch gar nicht mehr bestehen
da gibt es dem ist definitiv ein
parlaments vor reit und ich bin sicher
die abgeordneten des deutschen
bundestags und der landtage werden dies
auch deutlich machen die
sozialdemokraten im bundestag sind ja
bereits soweit wir werden auch ein
brinkhaus und wir uns abladen davon
überzeugen dass sie ihre tätigkeit auch
wieder aufnehmen müssen dass ich ihre
arbeit auch wieder erledigen müssen denn
der ort des geschehens ist das parlament
wir sind die erste gewalt im stadion
ohne beschlussfassung des parlamentes
gegen eigentlich gar nicht vielen dank
wolfgang kubicki dass sie sich die zeit
genommen haben danke schön euer geschick
japan so weit also die pressekonferenz
jetzt außer der reihe von angela merkel
sehr viele antworten jetzt noch mal
gegeben aber natürlich typisch in dieser
krise gibt es auch noch immer viele
frank vor allem wann das ganze ein ende
findet ende november ist jetzt an
geplant wir haben es gerade gehört
angela merkel will sich darauf nicht
festlegen jetzt also der 16 november das
große nächste datum auf das alle blicken
und bis dahin natürlich trotzdem
weiterhin alle informationen und
entwicklungen rund um die korona krise
hier in deutschland und weltweit
natürlich auf bild.de und damit möchten
wir uns für den moment verabschieden auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
um ist und sie hat glaube ich keinen
fehler begangen der darin besteht dass
sie gesagt wir müssen die kontakte
beschränken das ist nur teilweise
richtig wir müssen die kontakte
beschränken die ungeschützte stehen wenn
die menschen es zwei masken tragen
beispielsweise dann haben sie kleine
infektionsrisiko der können die kontakte
auch bestehen bleiben ich hätte mir
gewünscht hätte heute aufgefordert was
möglich ist für die menschen nicht mehr
rp zwei masten versorgen und damit einen
großen eigenschutz betreuen herr kubicki
die kanzlerin hat auch gesagt dass das
virus halbherzigkeit bestrafen würde und
hat diese maßnahmen verteidigt indirekt
auch gegen die kritik aus ihrer partei
ist das was sie fordern halbherzig also
zunächst einmal sind die einzigen das
fordern sondern es gibt andere computer
logan gestern abend noch mal professor
will ich der biologe der charité in
berlin herrscht reger schmidt chanasit
der kollege palmer als oberbürgermeister
von tübingen macht das gerade das er ft2
masken an die alten und pflegeheime
verteilt und dort niemand mehr rein oder
raus kann der nicht vorher getestet
worden ist etwas was ich beispielsweise
im mai schon gefordert habe und die uns
fragen wir sind warum das so lange
gedauert hat
es ist geschehen ist aber wenn sie dann
kontakt beschränkung machen wollen dann
dürfen sie jetzt keine u-bahn s-bahn und
erfahren lassen heute morgen
beispielsweise berlin hand die u-bahn
wieder so eng an eng an eng mit einander
bestimmt und menschen über 20 30 minuten
zusammengepfercht waren
und zwar nicht mit masken den
eigenschutz beinhalten also insofern wir
die kontakt beschränkung in der u-bahn
wie es nicht sinnvoller als und
gastronomischen betrieben die mittel
jene konzepten habe die kanzlerin sagt
auch über corona das ist eine
naturkatastrophe mit der wir umgehen
müssen teilen sie die analyse ist krone
eine naturkatastrophe
jedenfalls ist an erhebliche
herausforderung für die medizin für die
wissenschaft wurde für die gesellschaft
insgesamt ich teile das das ist eine
wirklich große herausforderung ist aber
wir wollen nicht zurück schauen
gleichwohl gibt es eine reihe von fragen
bis heute nach acht monaten bin ich alle
gesundheitsämter an das elektronische
system dem ist angeschlossen also das
deutsche elektronische meldesystem
infektionen
dann hätte man ein lagebild was
ausreichend wäre wir haben immer noch
probleme mit der krone at man muss sich
wirklich
warum wir so viel geld ausgegeben haben
wenn die funktionstüchtigkeit
eingeschränkt ist wir sind doch ein land
was technisch versiert ist wir können
noch genauso wie taiwan oder südkorea
mit der elektronischen möglichkeiten
umgehen da ist mittlerweile mehr nach zu
arbeiten als das den beteiligten lieb
ist kubicki viele menschen fragen sich
natürlich auch was passiert dann nach
dem november die kanzlerin wollte da
jetzt nicht spekulieren was ist ihr
gefühl was haben sie da mitgenommen aus
der pressekonferenz
glauben sie dass dann wieder geöffnet
wird oder haben sie das gefühl wenn sie
der kanzlerin zu hören dass dieser
lockdown viel länger dauern könnte also
von gefühlen freuen wir uns nicht reden
weil ich bin hin und hergerissen
zwischen optimismus dass wir es gewinnen
könnt auch mit der technik technische
innovation die wir haben die
medizinischen fortschritten und der
sorge dass man selbst gefangen ist in
der argumentation die man aufbaut was
passiert wenn wir ende november bei 52
inzidenz in deutschland weit über
hunderttausend sind wird er noch das
wort gesetzt und lange soll das
umgesetzt werden wie lange kann sich
dieses land leisten zehn milliarden euro
pro monat auszugeben dafür das
gastronomische betriebe waren das die
kunst nicht mehr stattfinden kann etwas
was ja auch zur gesundheit wir müssen es
immer wieder überlegen wir haben bei
allen maßnahmen die wir machen auch
kollateralschäden menschen vereinsamen
menschen werden depressiv menschen in
dem er zum arzt menschen haben keine
lebensperspektive hat das ist auch ein
problem
wir brauchen auch planbarkeit wieder für
unsere wirtschaft all das wie gesagt ist
bisher nicht gegeben wenn wir nicht zur
planbarkeit des lebens zurückkommen
da wird die unsicherheit zu einem
wesentlichen faktor der
gesellschaftlichen spaltung werden und
vor allen dingen auf das wirtschafts
nieder jetzt ist dieser locker und die
entscheidung dazu in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gefallen es
gibt schon seit längerem viel kritik
daran dass das ganze immer vorbei am
parlament vorbei an der opposition
entschieden wird was ist jetzt ihr plant
für die kommenden wochen und monate wenn
es im dezember tatsächlich weitere
locker maßnahmen gibt um als opposition
dann dort auch ein mitspracherecht zu
haben
aber zunächst bin ich der kanzlerin
dankbar dass ich jetzt parlament dieses
beteiligen wie sie gesagt ich gerne
bereit zu berichten über maßnahmen die
die npd beschlossen die ihr gemeinsam
ist wichtiger dass wir vorher
diskutieren bevor maßnahmen ins werk
gesetzt wären wenn man nur noch
berichten entgegen leben darf
wenn noch einmal stimmt der bundestag
hat das infektionsschutzgesetz
novelliert im märz wir haben
verordnungsermächtigungen geschaffen das
sich für den bund für die länder aber
wir haben keine ermächtigung geschaffen
von der verordnung so gebrauch zu machen
dass grundrechte praktisch gar nicht
mehr bestehen da gibt es dem ist
definitiv ein parlaments vor weit und
ich bin sicher die abgeordneten des
deutschen bundestags und der landtage
werden dies auch deutlich machen die
sozialdemokraten im bundestag sind ja
bereits soweit wir werden auch ein
brinkhaus unions abgeordneter von
innovationen dass sie ihre tätigkeit
auch wieder aufnehmen müssen dass sich
ihre arbeit auch wieder erledigen müssen
denn der ort des geschehens ist das
parlament wir sind die erste gewalt im
stadion ohne beschlussfassung des
parlament ist geht eigentlich gar nicht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren